[Music]
hi everyone I'm Alexandra I'm a software
engineer at belleau where we're building
a product that acts as a manager's
co-pilot so helps you with your
one-on-ones and team meetings and
feedback that sounds like something that
would be useful to you check out fellow
app or come and talk to me afterwards I
don't want to talk to you about today is
something completely different which
I've been working on in my spare time
and it's this app that I built that lets
you access the internet without actually
having a data or Wi-Fi connection and it
transfers all of the data that you need
over SMS so why would I build something
like this when we already have data on
Wi-Fi connections all over the world so
I come from a country where a data plan
for 2 gigabytes a month cost me 55 euros
and it only works in my hometown and the
internet prices are so extremely
expensive of this country that 3/4 of a
million people are still using dial-up
internet in their homes I come from
Canada so the internet is so so
expensive just when I'm at home that
when I'm traveling somewhere I like to
come to Berlin the prices are just
totally out of my price range I really
really like to travel so this data
problem is time an issue for me when I
travel I love to visit Paris and the
streets look kinda like this so I got
lost really easily in a grid-like
structure so when I'm over here I need
data so I can figure out how to get
around and I could technically download
a map offline and use that but that
doesn't give me transit directions which
is something I really need when I walk
an hour in the wrong direction I need
the subway to get back home so when I
was trying to come up with a solution
for this problem I noticed like I can't
afford the data plans but SMS without a
data plan cost about 15 cents per
message so I tried to work around that
when I was starting a solution to this
problem chat bots were the big thing at
the time so the first way I approach
this problem is I set up a Python server
that I could send an SMS to the server
would have unlimited access to the
Internet it would grab all the data that
I needed for the directions and then it
would text it back to me so I could do
something really simple like say how do
I get from point A to B and I would get
the
Google Maps API directions back in one
SMS and so I could do this for just
about 30 cents per drection which is
pretty good compared to what I would
have been hit paying for data otherwise
and like this really worked and I used
it a lot when I was traveling but the
issue is when you get a little bit of
access to the Internet you start to
crave it quite a bit more so I was
building all these one-off integrations
to like figure out ratings for a
restaurant I want to go see or translate
a word I didn't know and do all this
stuff and building out all these
integrations as one-off took up a lot of
time and so I thought there must be a
better way I let's build a browser and
that's what I'm gonna show you today so
your two main components to the project
I did there is the Android app on one
side and the server and node.js on the
other so yeah the app I made in Android
because I it was just for me I don't
have an iPhone so I didn't care about a
iOS and I'm using Java instead of :
because Java had a lot more on
stackoverflow about SMS and so that was
a good solution for me cuz I'm not an
app developer the server I didn't know
Jay asked because I thought it would be
really really funny to use JavaScript on
the server where it does not belong to
make this JavaScript less browser where
it's supposed to be and then in the
middle I use Twilio to facilitate the
communication so Twilio is a service
that does a lot of things but what I
used it for is I bought a phone number
from it and it let me set up an endpoint
to forward all may SMS queue so I can
send a text message to my Twilio phone
number and it'll forward all those
messages to my server so before I jump
into the project just to set up like a
limitation that I had to deal with SMS
can only handle 160 characters at a time
so if I want to create a browser I'm
gonna have to transmit this data less
than one tweet at a time
so remember concepts on the issue like
this Google webpage looks very very
small it's just a text box and the logo
and a button but the thing is if you
actually look at the page source not
including any CSS not including any of
the images or any sources that are being
loaded in this web page is a quarter of
a million
characters long so if we were to
transmit this entire thing it would take
1300 SMS not including the ones they're
gonna be dropped along the way
so in Twilio fees alone I would have
been paying $10 just to transmit this
Google page and that's not gonna get me
very far and kind of defeats the whole
purpose of being a cheap solution so
we're gonna have to do a lot on this
page to get it to work but if we were to
imagine what this Google page look like
if we were building it up from scratch
we wouldn't imagine like all the CSS to
make everything line up properly or all
the external sources being loaded in we
were just imagine this little bit of
HTML that sets up the form in the text
box which is really all we need and this
only takes one SMS so this is how we're
gonna have to envision a lot of the web
pages to make this project to actually
work so we're gonna walk through the
lifecycle of a request and that's
starting on the Android side in the app
so right off the bat we get into this
huge limitation with SMS because the URL
spec says that a URL can be 2,000
characters long
so that could take up 13 SMS which is
already a lot more than we want to have
to deal with so the first thing we're
gonna do on the outside and the app just
looks like this where there's a text box
and a go about in very very simple
browser so we're gonna start off by
chopping off everything on the world
that we don't really need so the browser
is gonna be very text-based browser so
we're not gonna allow any kind of cool
single page applications so we can chop
off anything that has like the pound
symbol page whatever we don't want me
tracking IDs we don't like the query
parameters so everything in black after
the URL there we can get rid of and same
with a HTTP www.a the start of the URL
because it's kind of assumed that all
websites have that anyway so the part in
yellow is what we're going to be sending
over as an SMS and that's gonna look
something like this so I'm not going to
cover the Android side of things too too
much but essentially what happens is we
check to make sure we have send receive
and write permissions on Android and
then we use their very simple SMS
manager API which lets you just specify
the destination phone number which in
this case is our Twilio one
I specify the text that you want to send
and then it just gets sent off
so then Twilio picks up on this message
and it converts it into a format that
the server can actually read so it comes
with a whole bunch of metadata shown
here we're only gonna really care about
the body who it's to and who it's from
so we know who to send this message back
to so this message got sent over to the
server which we're gonna look at next so
a lot of us are probably working in
react or some kind of like component
izing library or framework all day so we
kind of forget how big our HTML ends up
really being because we're only dealing
with these little tiny components at
once if you're like me and you press
view page source accidentally instead of
inspect element all the time you'll end
up with this massive massive wall of
text wondering like how on earth are web
pages that ended up being this big and
this is the like this is what Google
source page looks like this is what
we're gonna have to deal with and this
is what we're gonna have to parse before
sending it back over through our texts
but there are a lot of things that we
can remove from this off the bat like we
don't care about comments we don't care
about how our data we don't care about
CSS or any of that stuff so there's a
lot of stuff we can get off take off
pretty easily to get us to work on the
server-side what we're gonna do is start
by grabbing the URL that told us on tell
us making a request to that URL by
prepending Lee HTTP to it and then we're
gonna use a library called cheerio
which is jQuery for the server side
pretty much and we're just gonna use
that to get the body off of the HTML
because jQuery makes that quite easy and
then once we have this body we're gonna
start to remove a bunch of the HTML and
for that I use a library called sanitize
HTML so line four that I highlighted
lets you specify specific tags in the
HTML that you want to allow so here
we're only going allow anchor tags
inputs and forms because in my opinion
those are the only elements that in a
text-based browser really provide any
kind of value to the user line 7 is hand
that are highlighted shows the
specific attributes on those tags that
we are going to allow so we're not gonna
allow class name because we don't have
CSS anyway we're not gonna allow image
tags because we can't really load images
over this mess and so we're only gonna
start loading these things
the last bit that's highlighted in the
exclusive filter so sanitized HTML lets
us specify a function of the tags and
attributes to decide whether we want to
show certain things so I one of the
examples I have there is we're going to
get rid of all of the hidden inputs
because the user can't see those anyways
so it's not gonna provide any value and
we're gonna get rid of policy URLs and
terms and conditions because no one's
gonna click on those anyways so it's
kind of wasted space so now we have
essentially a whole bunch of text and a
couple of tags left in the HTML so we're
gonna start to compress this text and we
could use something like gzip but that's
not fun so we're gonna forget about and
it kind of really confessor like that so
in the English language there are a lot
of words that we use super often like
done and and there are a lot of single
letter words or single letters that just
aren't words like every letter except
for a and a so one of the ways of
compressing the text that I've done is
every very very common English word can
be mapped directly to a single letter
that isn't a word on its own so
everything that's dubbed becomes tea
everything goes and becomes ampersand or
whatever letter and on the Android side
when we're doing the decompression we
know that if that letter is there on its
own it means the because it's not a word
otherwise and to do that it's very very
simple we just have to set up a
dictionary and mapping these words to
their shorter versions and then go
through the text and do a replace all
another way of compressing the texts is
through the source api's so if we're
visiting a website like Wikipedia there
are gonna be a lot of big words there
that don't need to be that big so what
we can do is find those very large words
use a thesaurus API and see if there is
a matching synonym that's much shorter
so penitential
is 12-letter weird I think twelve or
fourteen letters and jail is a
four-letter word and in most contacts
they're gonna mean the same thing you
don't really care which ones being used
so we're gonna do this replacement and
this is a 66% compression which is quite
a good compression rate the last way
we're gonna start compressing are the
text in our hTML is by replacing links
so when you're using a website on your
phone you don't care what a link
actually is you just care that it takes
you to where it's supposed to take you
but links can be really really long like
up to 2,000 characters so instead of
sending over these links that no one is
actually going to be reading we're gonna
replace them with really short random
strings so when a user clicks on a link
on the app side that short link is
what's going to be sent back to the
server the server is gonna know that
short link means this long link and it's
gonna fetch the correct data to send
back to us and that's gonna look like
this so I'm using Redis to store these
Mac these pairings of short URLs to long
URLs because we don't need anything
super persistent because most links are
not gonna be clicked on anyway and the
web page is probably gonna be gone in
five minutes so what we're doing here is
there's a function that takes the phone
number from the user and the actual URL
that is on the webpage and it's gonna
store it in Redis where the key is the
phone number and the short URL so it's
really easy to retrieve when it's sent
back and then the value of that is the
full URL now the last bit of compression
we're gonna do is on the HTML itself so
we've compressed all the English text
we've compressed all the like tags and
attributes but we still are gonna have a
lot of large tags like this and things
like input or type and name and value
and all those tags that we do allow are
gonna show up pretty often so we're
gonna we can remove those and replace
them a nice thing about the SMS
character set is that it supports all of
the English tag or all of the English or
letters and numbers and things that you
see on an English keyboard plus the
whole Greek
alphabet so what we've done here since
all the individual letters already used
by our English compression the tax
compression we're gonna start mapping
specific HTML tags and combinations of
symbols to these Greek letters so I
tried to map it by color here the open
bracket input matches the first
character type equals open quotation
mark is a second character and so on so
this brings it down this brings
something like this down from 44
characters to 12 characters which is
going to provide a significant
compression so now the HTML is ready to
be sent out but an annoying thing about
SMS is that there's no guarantee of
delivery and there is no guarantee that
it's going to be delivered in the right
order either so you might end up with a
situation where we've sent out six SMS
but only four of them got there and
they're all out of order so we're not
gonna really care about the part where
the SMS are dropped in this project
because it's just a small project for me
to access the internet for fun and if we
did worry about that we would have to
build out an entire packet delivery
network where we have to figure out
which messages were dropped how do we
recover from that and that's just a
little bit more effort but we are gonna
worry about this out of order problem
and to solve that the HTML that we have
is going to be divided up into the 160
character limits and we're gonna prepend
some metadata to the start of each
message that shows as a total number of
messages in this webpage and then the
index where that SMS falls so that when
we put the HTML back together it's in
the correct order and to send out those
messages we're just gonna use to Leo's
library very simple just say Giulio send
message and it goes off and that's all
we have to do so now these messages are
sent and we're ready to start getting
them again on the Android side so
Android has anything called a broadcast
receiver which is something that listens
out for certain signals that are sent
within your phone so here we've set up a
broadcast receiver that listens out for
messages coming in specifically from the
number that we
until yo so what this is doing is it's
just listening for that message to come
in and then it's grabbing the text from
that message and sending it over to an
activity which is androids way of saying
a new view and in that new view the
first thing we're gonna have to do is
reverse that Greek letter conversion
that we did so we get the proper HTML
back we're gonna reverse the shortened
English words we're gonna add some
spaces between closing and opening tags
just so that there's a little bit of
format within our page because there's
no CSS otherwise to make it look good so
we're gonna try to break it up a little
bit and then we're going to load the
HTML so Android has my favorite feature
ever which is called a web view and a
web view is something that lets you have
a like a little version of Chrome within
your app and this was the most exciting
feature for me because going into this
project I didn't know that you could
pass a web view an actual HTML string I
thought you could only pass it a URL to
load and so I thought that I was gonna
have to build my own actual browser and
rendering engine and that didn't sound
like tons of fun so this takes care of
everything chrome is just gonna render
everything properly for us and this is
what it ends up looking like so if we
load or if we load Google dots yay on
the Left we have what this actually
looks like in the app which is basically
what Google looked like 15 years ago on
the right side is the SMS that you can
actually see coming in in your default
messaging app on your phone so this
entire webpage took just 3 SMS to
transmit instead with a 1300 that it
would have otherwise and the code that
we wrote isn't specific to Google it's
applicable to anything any text-based
web site so if we we could just hard
code this web site instead like on the
one of the first few slides where it's
just one SMS to transmit and that would
have taken like even even less data this
one over so I have dial-up in the name
of the talk and it was really curious
how does this actually compare it to
dial-up internet on my phone
loading Google takes about two seconds
usually
like regular data or Wi-Fi on dial-up a
couple years ago it would have taken
about a minute to do and using the app
that I built it takes about 10 seconds
when my phone's actually working so if
you're somewhere where you don't have
any other access to the internet like me
when I was traveling to Europe 10
seconds is not that bad to wait for a
website to load SMS is not secure at all
it is subject to be intercepted it is
not secure so one of the ways I've
prevented people from misusing this is
by removing any kind of sign-in links
from from the HTML and doing that but
otherwise like this is not something
that should be used to log into anything
on the right side though because this is
a custom browser there's no tracking or
anything so it's technically more
private than your general a general
browser something we would have made
this project quite a bit easier is using
MMS instead of SMS so I could have
transmitted the entire website just by
compressing a little bit and sending it
over for very very little for not that
much more expensive but that's not fun
so I didn't do that way there are a lot
of things that I want to do with this
project so phones are by nature
bi-directional and communications so we
could do something really easily with
WebSockets because the server can just
paying the phone whenever it wants we
could do Ajax so for web sites we visit
a lot like Twitter or something the
format of every tweet is exactly the
same so we could store the HTML and CSS
to recreate a proper Twitter on our
phone and then just use the SMS to get
the actual text content we could support
JavaScript might be a little difficult
because we're removing so much HTML but
it would be a really fun problem to
figure out how to map JavaScript to the
HTML on how to properly compress both
and then my favorite which is what I'm
working on now is a true dial-up for
this project so we're not doing real
dial-up because it's over SMS but we
could use a phone call to quickly
transmit data like dial-up used to work
and I think that would be quite a bit
cheaper it would take a lot it would be
much faster and
it would be real dial-up in that case
cuz you can use your phone well of the
loop web website was loading so there
probably a lot of you thinking this is
ridiculous there are some cards for this
purpose I didn't know about this till a
couple months ago so if you're
travelling to Europe you can get a SIM
card like 420 gigs for very very cheap
and 20 gigs compared to my two gigs at
home is essentially unlimited data so
this is what I get when I travel now and
it's it's a much better solution but
when I'm in Europe I usually come for
like the two weeks you're allowed with a
SIM card plus a day so my project still
comes in handy for that one extra day
and so my talk or my the code is
available on my github there's a link to
that from my website and yeah that's my
talk thank you
[Applause]
[Music]